while in Las Vegas president Trump could
not escape from reporters asking about
his Secretary of State and his quitting
Rex Tillerson took the unusual step
yesterday of appearing before cameras at
the State Department to answer questions
about whether he had insulted the
president and considered resigning
Margaret Brennan is at the White House
Margaret good morning good morning it is
extraordinary to have a Secretary of
State hold a press conference to pledge
his loyalty to the president but
Tillerson knew that President Trump was
angry and he sent out his own
spokesperson to deny that he ever called
the president a [ __ ] it was fake news
it was a totally phoney soon president
Trump's trip to console victims in Las
Vegas was dogged by an explosive story
claiming that Secretary of State
Tillerson had called him a [ __ ] and
nearly quit following a July meeting at
the Pentagon
he puts Americans and America first he's
smart in an attempt to assuage the
president's anger the press of her
Secretary of State called an impromptu
press conference and said he had no
plans to exit I'm not from this place
but the places I come from we don't deal
with that kind of petty nonsense mr.
Trump who had been informed of Tillerson
comments in July said he appreciated the
statement total confidence in this I
have total confidence the blow-up
happened after President Trump and
Tillerson sparred in July / sharply
differing views on the Iran nuclear deal
Tillerson was also frustrated he'd been
undermined on other key issues including
North Korea Venezuela and a Mideast
dispute who the hell wants to speak
about politics when I'm in front of the
Boy Scouts the Secretary of State a
lifelong Boy Scout was also dismayed by
mr. Trump's comments at a Boy Scout
gathering there's never been a
consideration in my mind Aleve Tillerson
continued on with his role we're gonna
do a lot of good saying he was committed
to being America's top diplomat senator
bob Corker chairman of the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee came to his
defense saying losing Tillerson
would do great harm to the nation he
ends up not being supported in the way
that I would hope a Secretary of State
would be supported senator corker added
that
there are people within the Trump
administration deliberately trying to
undercut Tillerson Authority and Nora
that can have an impact because even the
perception of a divide between the
president and his top diplomat can
weaken u.s. negotiating power and that
US national security Margaret thank you
so much